straightaway with the United Kingdom a
place whose very name after this week's
events is beginning to sound a bit
sarcastic because the UK this week voted
to leave the European Union a decision
that has shaken the world and not in a
Muhammad Ali beating Sonny Liston kind
of way more inner those IKEA meatballs
you love contain horse kind of way
and the fallout in Britain has been
Swift
and significant the BRIC decision is off
to a bit of a rough start here in London
at least stocks were in freefall
the pound historically weak and the
countries in the market for a new prime
minister that's right David Cameron
announced he would be stepping down in
the wake of the vote which should make
me happy but in this situation it
doesn't it's like catching an ice cream
cone out of the air because a child was
hit by a car I'll eat it I'll eat it but
it's tainted somehow and before before
you have any sympathy for David Cameron
you should know this whole vote was his
idea in the first place
we will give the British people a
referendum with a very simple in or out
choice yes Cameron proposed the in or
out choice himself which he normally
only does when he's deciding whether to
pigs mouth
meanwhile the brexit vote has boosted
its two most vocal backers Nigel Faraj
leader of the UK Independence Party and
three time cover model for punchable
face magazine Boris Johnson a shaved
orangutan with Owen versus
before and after the vote both men drove
home a common theme I believe that this
Thursday can be our country's
independent state let June the 23rd go
down in our history as our Independence
Day okay a couple of things there first
Britain was already independent it's
what many other countries celebrate
their independence from they're quoting
actually opened this week and features
the wholesale destruction of London
which is beginning to feel pretty
appropriate right now and I'm
not even sure the Prague brexit camp had
planned on winning because the next day
they started speaking a lot more
carefully about the promises that have
been made you might remember that
campaign bus which rent we sent the EU
350 million pounds a week let's fund our
National Health Service instead well
here's Nigel Faraj the morning after the
vote the 350 million pounds a week we
sent to the EU which we and will no
longer send to the EU can you guarantee
that's going to go to the NHS no I can't
and I would never have made that claim a
lot of mistakes they leave campaign me
oh no you're telling us it does seem
that Faraj will not correct factual
mistakes when they're on the side of
buses I therefore would encourage
Britain to take out bus ads reading
Nigel Faraj has spent hours trying to
put his own penis in his presume
he'll be silent about it and while the
benefits of a brexit may well have been
exaggerated the downsides could be all
too real prominent figures in Scotland
and Northern Ireland are advocating for
leaving the UK and rejoining the EU
meanwhile the EU is understandably
worried about other member nations
making exits of their own so it may well
negotiate as hard as possible to make an
example of Britain basically it seems
like whoever the next UK prime minister
is going to be whether it's Boris
Johnson or a racist tea kettle they are
going to be in for a rough few years
because once they invoke what's known as
article 50 they have just two years to
negotiate their withdrawal and future
relationship with the
you on top of which they'll have to
settle outstanding bills with the EU
hammer out new trade deals with dozens
of countries sift through thousands of
EU regulations and decide which ones to
keep and figure out how migration will
work and all the wild lives hang in the
balance
take this Portuguese woman who was lived
in the UK for years and has built a life
there I have two daughters one was born
in Portugal the second one was born in
me okay
and asked me this morning mum what is
going to happen to us
and I told them at this point no one
knows I don't know my future I don't
know how to explain my children what is
going to happen to the future perhaps I
can help you with that because it's easy
just tell them that they might be
screwed because a pigfucker called for a
vote a bus had some written on
it and then two idiots named Nigel and
Boris quoting president Bill Pullman
totally understand